peter king begins football morning in
america with a look at how one of the
brand new quarterbacks daniel jones gave
his team a fresh look at its future
available now at
profootballtalk.com all right sunday
superlatives for week three plenty of
great things to talk about coming out of
the third sunday of the season go well i
guess uh my my first superlative i want
to build like uh
building a team or claymation something
that way i don't know i'm not that smart
to figure out what i want to say here
you know i'm trying to say they're
building something special okay and this
has to do with two teams in the nfc
north no you can't take two i'm taking
two deal with it there's nothing you can
do what are you gonna do okay i'll be
okay you're gonna put me in a headlock
no okay here we go
two teams one of which is your minnesota
device don't take mine the other one get
the vikings i'm taking them both you're
not taking any credit for them you want
to crap on kirk cousins i'm not going to
listen right now okay but i do want to
give credit to the teams that are being
built the minnesota vikings and the
green bay packers okay i think they're
just we we got to talk about what
they're doing right now focus on the
package okay fine i will okay fine you
can all right so this is what i like
though so far here we are i'm drooling
on my mic is the packers 3-0
and we really haven't seen the offensive
output that we want to see yet from the
green bay packers as far as aaron
rodgers air show oh it's 350 yards no i
don't think that's what it's going to be
but i think that's what's scary is that
their offense is not even clicking yet
as far as all cylinders but they can
they're running the football they're
playing tough defense and it's only a
matter of time before rogers and the
offense come along to where i think
they're synchronized and really kind of
hitting on all cylinders but this is
like as dangerous as i've seen the
packers in a number of years because
again even though the offense isn't
pretty and special i go it's as
dangerous as it's ever been because
they're not worried about oh four yards
here five yards here aaron's gonna just
try to nickel and dime you and find ways
to make you know throw the ball and move
the ball down the field they're looking
to run the ball smash you and then take
big shots down the field and that's
where they're more dangerous and all the
other stuff is only a matter of time
before it comes along and i just say
watch out for green bay right now which
i want to say watch out for your
minnesota vikings too but go ahead but
the schedule has lined up favorably for
the packers you get a lot of these home
games you build your confidence your
offense gets better and then when you
have the tougher games coming up later
in the year yeah you are hitting on
exactly cylinders as opposed to being
thrown into the buzz saw early when
you're not ready for it and ending up
one and three and and having to fight
and scratch and claw the rest of the way
so i'm with you on the packers yeah they
are moving in the right direction and
like i said during the tv segment we
just did those wins in september are
money in the bank the vikings could have
won in green bay last week they're two
in one my superlative first one right
it's the john d filippo award because
you know usually like there's you name
something after somebody who has died
right he's still alive but he died as
the vikings offensive coordinator last
year right and i think the more that the
vikings coaching staff specifically the
offensive coaches can be reminded of
john d filippo the more likely they will
be to do what they did yesterday which
is give the ball to the running backs
give the ball to dalvin cook he is
unstoppable he
i don't want to say he's the best
running back in the nfl right now he's
up in the comments he's out there he's
out there yeah right and he's a
game-changer he he is man among boys he
there was a play yesterday where
he was toying with the defenders and
every time he has the ball there is an
explosion there is a burst there is a
quality about dalvin cook that is
unmatched currently by his opponents
yeah so just keep giving him the
football yeah they're gonna don't throw
the ball 31 times like here's what drove
me crazy last week i don't want to go
back and rehash the packers game but
when they're down 17 nothing they run
the ball they got away pops a 75-yard
touchdown right right and then when
they're trying to just get that one last
score they're throwing the ball into the
end zone into double coverage ride
dalvin cook 21 passes for kirk cousins
yesterday 10 in week one yeah 31 in week
uh two
let's go with les kirk cousins yeah more
dalvin cook more alexander madison more
mike boone they've got three great
running backs and they're leaning on
cook but if he needs a breather go with
the other two guys especially if he gets
injured hopefully he won't no go with
the other two guys keep doing what
you're doing running the football and
minimize the use of kirk cousins and
it's hard because you got a couple of
great receivers you're trying to keep i
mean i talked to adam feeling yesterday
after the game and he said you know you
never know are they just saying the
right things he said i don't care his
production is way down through three
games yeah right in last year i don't
care as long as we win but uh it's got
to be weird when
you know you're used to getting the ball
so much and now all of a sudden you're
doing all that work to get open and
you're caught right or you're blocking
most of the time but it's working
they're winning as long as they're
winning
then it's easy to get these guys they're
far more dangerous the way they're
playing right now than they were last
year with you know oh gosh we put up
some fake yards and points and it didn't
really matter or whatever it may be or
whenever the game was in a tough
situation they couldn't move the ball no
i mean i think your point's right mike
they need to be around
the way they're built is for kirk
cousins to throw the ball 20 to 25 times
a game when they throw it 31 times a
game you know that just tells you oh the
run game's not working they want to play
zimmer ball that's what i think we got
to start calling it it's zimmer ball
they want to run the ball they're gonna
play defense and they're gonna take a
shot or two down the field and really
mike i think it's a positive for your
vikings you know it's
they don't have a third receiver or a
good enough passing offense to be sexy
that way i mean it's really remarkable
actually we're sitting here in week
three in the nfl and i think if i ask
most people who the third receiver is
for the the minnesota vikings people
would go
hmm i'm not sure yeah i'm not sure right
and who is it chad baby you're right
that's it he's the only guy he's the
only guy we see out there kind of making
a a little bit of a a nuance for himself
uh in the passing game put up posters of
john d filippo everywhere in the
organization so they are constantly
reminded what happens if you pass the
ball too much you get fired or you don't
win games and they'll win the more they
keep doing what they did yesterday um
who needs a franchise quarterback is my
next superlative okay who needs um you
know uh and that means to the i'm going
talking about the indianapolis colts
with jacoby bersette you know here he is
two and one uh after three weeks beat
matt ryan and his 30 million dollar a
year oh gosh it's julio jones and calvin
ridley coming to town how are we gonna
keep up with them um do you think the
falcons would like a refund um i don't
know about a refund but they're
certainly not getting their total
money's worth right now not just out of
matter ryan but a few people i think
that's fair to say but the indianapolis
colts you know we talk about the cream
and the crop and the afc right and we go
okay we know it's the chiefs and the the
new england patriots
i don't know how you feel but i look at
the colts as being that next tier down
where i say watch out i mean what's not
to like about the colts jacoby
brissette's found his sea legs he's he's
got he knows how to play quarterback in
football every week it's been better and
better yesterday was phenomenal what was
it the first 16 passes of the day
complete 16 for 16. stands in the pocket
makes big throws they can run the
football they're good up front on
defense the only thing i worry about
with this colts team is their secondary
but regardless the colts they're not
going anywhere this is a team that uh i
think has showed us that they're they're
able to weather the storm without andrew
luck jacoby bersetta's handle are
capable of handling the reigns and he
has been phenomenal so far and and
congrats to the colts for being
two-in-one this is the best colts team
they've had really since tony dungy was
the coach but but you just wonder how
much better they'd be with andrew life
yeah sure but but they're still pretty
damn good without andrew luck and they
have turned the corner and moved on and
they're piling up the wins oh oh and by
the way they have the chiefs coming up
on sunday night football in a couple of
weeks and ended funny when andrew luck
retired i looked at the schedule and i
said that's that's right in the window
of that very early emergency flex maybe
the nfl will decide to get that game out
do not take that no no no that is going
to be a great game coming up in just 13
days all right
this is the winners win easily when they
should win easily award and it goes
primarily to the dallas cowboys because
they they managed to cover yeah make us
look smart the patriots failed to cover
thanks to jared him in the game and
throwing a pick six of jamal adams but
you know with the cowboys i mean it
would be very easy to stub your toe
against the crap team you go home you're
two and oh you're feeling good about
yourself and you just it's the dolphins
they're not trying to win we'll be fine
and and it was a little dicey there
early on yeah but you just keep plugging
away you don't give up you don't slump
your shoulders and the next thing you
know it's 31-6 or something like that
whatever the final score was it was a
blowout like it should have been but
that's what when you are a great team
and you are laying the foundation for a
special season there are games you
should win easily and you win easily
when you should win easily that's the
mark of a great team we've seen plenty
of teams we thought we were great lose
in a spot like that the cowboys to their
credit found their focus kept going and
won the game easily even though it was
ugly earlier yeah it was it was ugly i
mean you know they won easily easily but
it wasn't easy i guess it's the the best
way to say it because i do think early
on they were a little too loose and
aggressive and kind of trying to put on
a show and put the dolphins out of the
game like in the second quarter but
that's my point it can't go either way
when you get in that spot you can wake
you can just like all of a sudden say oh
we're down by seven in the third quarter
how is this going yeah and then you know
even with that you're right the sloppy
play and they're just not playing their
best football you never really felt like
miami had control of the football game
and then miami yeah had some
opportunities to make things very
interesting whether it was the drop
touchdown pass down the right sideline
or kenyon drake fumbling going in but
that's what bad teams do and you know
the good teams like the dallas cowboys
they're they're big they're physical
they fly around they hit you and they
just wore down that miami's dolphins
team and not only was dak press got good
but to have 200 yard rushers zico for
125 and pollard go from 103. um pretty
impressive uh for for for that that
offensive line and that run game in
general um yeah what do we got we got
time for one more no go ahead go ahead
um good thing we have that guy award
goes to deshaun watson in the houston
texans okay you know i know we're
sitting there getting ready for all the
our pre-game show on sunday night
football last night and deshawn watson i
know had a few bonehead plays or
especially one bonehead play where he
threw the ball backwards in a lateral
and set up the short field for the
chargers to get some points but oh my
gosh i mean desean watson just some of
the plays and throws he makes
are truly phenomenal i mean the the
houston texas could be sitting here 0-3
right now instead they're 2-1 and i'm
just amazed at desean watson's ability
to make big plays and big throws
week after week after week and yesterday
uh no run game to talk of but he just
you know whether it's buying time in the
pocket or just making laser beam throws
down the field he was phenomenal i'm
excited i don't even have a good grasp
of what went on in that game because
we're watching so much and but all i
know is every time i looked up desean
watson was making a jaw-dropping type
play and uh he's just some phenomenal
player here's the thing about desean
watson someone made this observation
over the weekend and it makes a lot of
sense we criticized the offensive line
in houston for getting desean watson
killed he holds onto the ball he does
way too long right right and he's always
trying as you say no even when it's
routine driving the first quarter he's
acting like the game is on the line you
can't survive doing that all the time
there are times when you got to make
your read faster you got to get rid of
the football you got to throw it away
you can't keep running around and
subjecting yourself to to potential
injury but like you said they're two and
one and the cults are two in one and it
feels like even though the jaguars we
should not give up on them it feels like
the colts and the texans are starting to
separate a little bit yeah from the back
and and you said they could be 0.3 well
there are five teams in the afc that are
oh and three we're going to talk about
the dregs of the american football
conference when pft live continues right
after this you know what drexel yeah
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports